[Musique]
comment distinguer une grande histoire
d'une simple aventure faut-il se fier au
premier rendez-vous Jean-Luc Mélenchon
j'ai découvert un jour où je partais à
la mairie et il y avait plein de petits
prospectus à ce moment-là et je me suis
dit c'est ce qui ce monsieur on dirait
[Applaudissements]
que c'est gentil donc pour moi le mot
tonton ça renvoie à François Mitterrand
une belle rencontre est-ce que ça
demande pas de dépasser sa première
impression
[Applaudissements]
pendant quelques années cette chaîne
faut-il forcément admirer l'autre pour
que ça dure
c'est un sacré personnage c'est
quelqu'un avec du caractère qui parle
bien qui prend les foules avec lui quand
il parle quel est le secret de la
réussite d'une relation entre un homme
politique et ses soutiens
qui sont ces 30% de jeunes Français qui
ont voté pour Jean-Luc Mélenchon en
espérant que c'est la majorité comment
le fondateur de la France insoumise
est-il devenu le rival de l'abstention
chez la nouvelle génération
pourquoi Yann Juliette dahlia est tant
d'autres citoyens et citoyennes de moins
de 30 ans ont décidé de faire confiance
aux plus âgé des candidats trois fois
perdants à la présidentielle moi ce qui
m'a poussé à voter pour Jean-Luc
Mélenchon déjà c'était le programme
environnemental si on veut un pays où on
vit bien forcément il faut faire des
réformes par rapport à la police la
lutte contre les violences sexistes
sexuelles donc un milliard pour lutter
contre les violences patriarcale on est
face à quelqu'un qui même s'il est plus
tout jeune il est pas jeune du tout il
est quand même à l'écoute de ce qui se
passe c'est important c'est la jeunesse
en fait qui qui va subir l'avenir du
pays et je dis bien subir
sans écouter mais tu te sens écouter par
un ancien c'est assez rare mine de rien
les jeunes et Jean-Luc Mélenchon sur
quoi repose cette union tout ce que ça
provoque c'est de la colère je peux être
que en colère ça me met en colère il y a
quelque chose dans la colère insoumise
qui relève de l'indignation c'est-à-dire
dire mais vous êtes fous quoi la
personnalité de Mélenchon est-elle
compatible avec le projet de ses neveux
et nièces l'enjeu pour ma génération
c'est de changer le système Jean-Luc
comprend-il vraiment les préoccupations
de la jeunesse insoumise je me suis pas
dit un jour ah les jeunes formidables
ils vont m'apprendre des trucs où sa
capacité de mise à jour a-t-elle atteint
c'est limite
bonsoir je suis pas obligé de réviser ma
position à cause de vous bah pourquoi
pas non non non j'ai plus envie
Jean-Luc Mélenchon va-t-il laisser sa
place
[Musique]
pourquoi pas c'est le flambeau paraît-il
si compliqué il a vraiment construit la
génération qui vient après les plus
jeunes vont me dire
on y est encore pas arrivé
[Musique]
c'est pas loin
faites mieux merci
[Musique]
pour commencer il faut poser les bases
une bonne relation c'est avant tout une
bonne communication hello
comment ça va sauf qu'en politique c'est
pas tout à fait comme dans la vraie vie
on a la chance de pouvoir faire appel à
des professionnels je suis Antoine
léoman j'ai 33 ans et je suis député de
l'Essonne pour la France insoumise alors
avant ça j'étais responsable de la
communication numérique de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon c'est à dire que je m'occupais
de ces réseaux sociaux globalement moi
je pense ça serait pas mal de faire des
plans de ce sens là parce que là-bas tu
as des bâtiments qui montrent qu'on est
dans un quartier pop sinon tu as
l'impression qu'on est on est à la
campagne
pendant 10 ans Antoine aeuré en
coulisses pour que son patron soit plus
qu'un homme politique les romans a les
codes des réseaux Mélenchon le talent
oratoire ensemble il crée Jean-Luc
l'influenceur j'ai commencé en 2013 je
crois qu'il devait y avoir quelque chose
comme 200 000 abonnés sur son et sont
mis sur sa page Facebook et aujourd'hui
on a deux millions sur Twitter et plus
d'un million je crois sur facebook la
ligne générale pour moi c'est tous les
médias m'intéressent tous sans exception
quel que soit le lieu quel que soit le
format il y a plein de jeunes qui sont
passés pour vérifier que c'était bien
ici donc ouais moi je suis plutôt plutôt
confiant mais j'ai connu la période où
vous avez des tracts avec des renéo on
se mettait de l'encre jusque dans les
trous de nez et quand on avait fait 5000
tracks bon ça on pensait qu'on était les
maîtres du monde bon si j'avais su à
l'époque que je ferai en une semaine 11
millions de vues sur Tik Tok je sais pas
peut-être que je me serais évanouie
jusqu'au dernier moment on aura
l'impression qu'il va y avoir personne
on arrive à être l'homme politique
numéro 1 sur les réseaux sociaux en
considérant que c'est pas des outils de
communication mais que c'est des outils
d'information qui permettent de faire
passer des idées et qui permettent de
construire quelque chose dans la durée
c'est le contournement du de la sphère
officielle donc nous qui sommes pointus
aigu qui avons calibrer un message on va
pouvoir bon passer à travers ça
qu'est-ce qu'on prend si vous dit pas
que ça marche à tous les coups dans
l'agenda médiatique
des gens qui nous intéressent nous avec
Antoine Jean-Luc a trouvé un de ses
meilleurs entremetteurs politiques en
même temps qui de mieux qu'un ancien
centriste pour convaincre les citoyens
de se laisser séduire par la gauche moi
j'étais plutôt de droite j'étais plutôt
côté Beyrout si j'avais pu voter en 2007
j'aurais votéro au premier tour j'aurais
voté Sarkozy au deuxième donc j'étais
vraiment bien parti à droite et c'est
vraiment le moment où c'est le hasard
mais c'est comme ça où j'ai découvert
Mélenchon avec un bouquin qui s'appelle
kit sans nightus je me suis dit qu'il
était génial que j'étais d'accord avec
tout ce qui racontait
parce que en fait on a fait un stop avec
avec un raccord local j'ai dit faut
voter pour lever voter pour lever comme
ça maintenant je suis devenu lever je
m'appelle lever les jeunes si on a
beaucoup un vesti les réseaux sociaux
c'est parce que on s'est dit que les
jeunes votaient peu dans l'ensemble et
que donc il fallait les convaincre
d'aller voter
là chez les jeunes on a fait des scores
vraiment hyper impressionnants quoi chez
les jeunes et
particulièrement chez les jeunes dans
les quartiers populaires ce qu'on essaye
de faire c'est de les convaincre des
idées politiques qu'on porte et du fait
que c'est les idées de l'avenir un
projet d'avenir pas une histoire d'un
soir d'élection il y a l'aspect
électoral bien sûr qui est un aspect
d'urgence entre guillemets il faut qu'on
gagne mais il y a l'aspect plus long
terme on essaye de gagner une bataille
culturelle construire une relation
durable avec les citoyens les convaincre
d'adhérer à un projet de rupture ça
demande d'y croire à fond quitte à
paraître un peu fan merci à toutes et à
tous d'être venus si nombreux je
suis par ailleurs mais bon je vous dis
juste une chose on a la possibilité de
tout changer dans ce pays on a la
possibilité de faire le SMIC à 1500
euros le blocage des prix la retraite à
60 ans supprimer parcoursup dont je sais
que c'est un énorme problème ici nous
aurons celui que vous attendez
maintenant pour prendre la parole comme
premier ministre Jean-Luc Mélenchon
plus qu'un patron pour moi ça a été
d'abord un mentor
j'ai coupé la parole
aux presque le meilleur des nôtres
on prend tous les bulletins pour que
personne sache qu'on va faire ensuite on
rentre
dans le bateau on choisit le bulletin le
plus intéressant c'est celui où on voit
le
voir avec les mains voter victoire en
France les personnes plus âgées vont
plus voter que les autres
et il arrive que quand l'âge vient on
devient plus craintif plus conservateur
et on n'aime pas trop que tout change
tout couche tout le temps et on trouve
que les jeunes sont bien agités et qui
devraient être un peu plus calme
Mélenchon l'homme qui a trouvé le secret
de la jeunesse éternelle une histoire
vraie ou juste une story de plus le
profil des élus vise à toucher les
citoyens au cœur âge origine
géographique et sociale valeur façon
d'être les points communs et les
différences sont scrutés jugées en
politique l'algorithme peut donner des
matchs improbables comme un homme de 71
ans avec des Jones ou un Antoine Léo man
avec des habitants des quartiers
populaires j'ai pas grandi dans un
quartier populaire j'ai pas grandi non
plus dans une ville de la périphérie de
Paris j'ai grandi dans une petite ville
de province comme on dit Châteauroux ok
je suis blanc c'est ça la question c'est
CHU blanc mais en réalité moi les
problèmes que j'ai rencontré dans mon
enfance qui sont des problèmes liés à la
ruralité et pas au quartier populaire
c'est énormément des problèmes qui sont
similaires au quartier populaire moins
de racisme selon vous est-ce qu'il y a
pas des moyens de faire en sorte que la
jeunesse qui vit en banlieue est plus
envie de s'investir en politique et de
se représenter
le boulot rien n'est jamais cadeau les
jeunes ça existe pas surtout si t'es
pauvre surtout si tu viens de milieux
populaire la seule consigne c'est
battoir rien n'est jamais cadeau mais
certaines
mesures savent de son destin
l'environnement social joue aussi un
grand rôle pour rappel la lutte contre
parcoursup et son système scolaire
élitiste figure au programme de la
France insoumise
en quoi Mélenchon serait-il le mieux
placé pour représenter la jeunesse de
banlieue
une jeunesse connectée certes
il y a pas de jambes photos de Jean-Luc
et moi et tout quand on se prend dans
les bras
mais une jeunesse qui attend surtout
l'étape d'après trouver enfin cette
personne qui comprend leurs besoins une
personne qui incarne le progrès social
c'est parfois je me dis je me dis que la
journée elle est finie mais non elle est
pas fini comment ça se passe la première
fois la première fois qu'on se motive
pour aller voter et qu'il faut donner sa
confiance à un inconnu est-ce qu'on se
lance tête baissée les yeux fermés ou
plutôt avec prudence j'ai voté utile
c'est-à-dire que Jean-Luc Mélenchon
c'est pas le choix parfait c'est
vraiment juste un bon début pour
atteindre des objectifs
je m'appelle dahlia j'ai 25 ans j'ai
toujours grandi et vécu en banlieue j'ai
une licence de japonais et je travaille
dans une épicerie spécialisée asiatique
système de vote déjà on lui même et
piété dedans
[Musique]
sidalia et ça serait Yasmine ont décidé
de soutenir Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est
avant tout une question de foi et de
trauma j'ai grandi dans une ville où
j'avais des amis quand j'étais au
collège qui est arrivée un jour à
l'école et ils avaient des bleus sur le
corps parce qu'ils étaient partis en
garde à vue parce que leur seul erreur
c'est d'être parti faire les courses
sans leur justificatif d'identité en
banlieue en fait on est conditionné à
penser à ça c'est à dire que si on ne le
fait pas on sait qu'on risque d'avoir
des problèmes
Sarcelles au nord de Paris comme dans
beaucoup d'autres banlieues la moitié
des votants a glissé un bulletin
Mélenchon dans l'urne à la dernière
présidentielle
promesse de réformer la police soutient
à la communauté musulmane Jean-Luc a
rallumé un espoir
[Musique]
je vais aller prier
je veux bien s'il te plaît
la prière c'est quelque chose qui a une
face importante sauf que de base je suis
censé prier à des moments précis dans la
journée mais pour des raisons de laïcité
je ne prie pas sur mon lieu de travail
et du coup les jours où je travaille je
rate mes prières donc en rentrant
forcément je les rattrape c'est un
moment où je sais que personne ne va me
déranger c'est mon moment à moi ça me
prend quelques minutes dans la journée
et ces quelques minutes de pur silence
autour de moi
[Musique]
je comprends de quoi il s'agit j'ai
moi-même été un jeune croyant
puis les circonstances de l'existence
éloigné du discours de la pratique de la
foi catholique donc je suis pas surpris
qu'un jeune soit croyant ça ne me paraît
pas être une monstruosité de temps en
temps comme ça dans ma vie je suis
choquée parce qu'il m'entoure c'est à
dire que je peux rencontrer quelqu'un
être ami avec cette personne pendant des
années et des années et d'un coup cette
personne me dit une monstruosité raciste
on m'explique qu'on me déteste et qu'on
déteste ceux qui me ressemblent
enfin non qu'on me déteste pas moi parce
que moi je suis pas comme les autres
justement si en fait moi aussi je suis
comme ça je suis exactement comme les
autres les autres que tu détestes c'est
à dire les Arabes et les musulmans
devine quoi
mauvaise nouvelle j'en suis une
patrie la républicaine elle est à tous
ses enfants
cette jeune femme c'est ma compatriote
je ressens une profonde
idée d'attachement et je ne supporte pas
ceux qui voudraient provoquer dans ce
pays cette coupure abominable la voix de
passage c'est pas essayer d'extirper la
religion du cœur des gens ça ne sert à
rien c'est un truc qui a changé depuis
que depuis que tu t'es remises prier
tout doucement c'est que moi je te sens
beaucoup plus sereine depuis c'est le
cas c'est le cas je suis beaucoup plus
sereine j'ai moins de pression j'ai
l'impression d'avoir moins de pression
sur les épaules un discours de tolérance
vis-à-vis des religions étonnants connus
et reconnu pour ses positions
anti-communautariste Jean-Luc Mélenchon
renie-t-il son passé mais je sais pas
peut-être qu'il y a 30 ans j'aurais pas
réagi comme ça tout m'insupportait les
bonnes soeurs qui passaient encore net
les autres et puis après vous recevez la
leçon de la vie vous dites ça n'a pas de
sens d'être comme ça ça n'a pas de sens
parce que si vous êtes un anticlérical
forcené qui ne supporte aucune pratique
religieuse ça vous élimine un nombre de
gens considérables autour de vous
opportunisme électorale
antiracisme sincère Jean-Luc Mélenchon
met sa capacité de remise en question au
service de la lutte contre un ennemi que
lui et dahlia ont en commun j'ai grandi
à Garges-les-Gonesse dans le 95 j'avais
envie de faire mon devoir de citoyenne
d'une manière ou d'une autre donc je me
suis proposé pour dépouiller et Garges
c'est une ville c'est un melting pot en
fait il y a toutes les cultures qui sont
mélangées et quand on marche dans les
rues agave on n'a pas l'impression que
le racisme existe et après on se
retrouve on ouvre le premier vote et
c'est Marine Le Pen et on se dit ah ils
sont où ces gens dans la vraie vie
exactement ils sont où en fait
je me suis dit mais dans quel monde je
vis finalement
tout de suite on se dit mais qu'est-ce
qui va se passer pendant ces élections
je suis franco égyptienne j'ai pas envie
de continuer de vivre dans un pays qui
me déteste parce que j'ai envie d'avoir
des enfants un jour j'ai pas envie de
leur donner un pays qui les déteste non
plus enfin c'est pas c'est pas un
objectif
combattre l'extrême droite par tous les
moyens lutter contre le racisme
quotidien c'est aussi partir en guerre
contre un adversaire bien plus difficile
à neutraliser
ce serait mentir de dire que qu'il n'y a
pas de racisme d'État c'est à dire qu'on
est dans un pays où quelque soit notre
statut social à partir du moment où on
n'est pas blanc on aura des difficultés
quand on ressent justement le ce
privilège d'être un homme blanc
il faut que les autres vous le disent au
début moi j'ai commencé par dire non
mais ça va pas c'est quoi le privilège
d'un homme blanc quand il est pauvre m'a
dit bon va te le raconter et puis quand
on vous le raconte vous dites c'est pas
que faux quoi et parce que ça touche à
tout ça touche à l'intime vous vous
définiriez comment alors être humain je
n'appartiens à aucune communauté fondée
sur la couleur de peau ça jamais quelle
horreur
qui peut affirmer aujourd'hui ne pas se
définir par sa couleur de peau pour
qu'il intime n'est-il toujours pas
politique
peut-être pour ceux qui peine à prendre
conscience de leur privilèges
pour commencer réconfortant comme plat
Jean-Luc Mélenchon il incarne pas
vraiment l'anti-racisme tel qu'on
aimerait le voir en France mais c'est un
bon début c'est-à-dire que si je devais
faire des choix par rapport à
l'antiracisme en France politiquement
parlant je voterai pas Jean-Luc
Mélenchon
c'était quelque chose qui était bien
plus présent dans le discours de Poutou
que dans le discours de Mélenchon sauf
que encore une fois il s'agirait d'unir
la gauche c'est trop mon alliance on
passe un bon moment
[Musique]
donc si je t'aime
je sais pas si tu aimerais autant si tu
savais pas cuisiner
[Musique]
la passion du début à la découverte de
l'autre et de son univers les yeux le
cœur tout est grand ouvert
[Musique]
il est beau mon cœur il est beau mon
cœur
on se laisse prendre par la main jusqu'à
Annecy pour la Marche des fiertés en
soutient à la communauté
lgbtqia+ et pas avec n'importe qui avec
toute la famille
on parle assez peu politique dans ma
famille et en arrivant à Paris du coup
j'ai rencontré des personnes qui m'ont
politisées
[Musique]
fraîchement diplômé des Arts et Métiers
une école d'ingénieurs et donc je suis
ingénieur en CDI la vie parisienne la
politique Mélenchon Yann a tout
découvert en même temps en 2017 j'étais
pas politisé j'avais eu un papier dans
ma boîte aux lettres de de Emmanuel
Macron qui avait dit le candidat des
jeunes c'est notre projet et tout
et du coup
Emmanuel Macron
j'assume plus maintenant mais c'est une
erreur de parcours une erreur de
jeunesse une
erreur que peut reconnaître le vote gay
pour Mélenchon ne va pas toujours de soi
Macron Le Pen et même Zemmour sont aussi
appelés dans les urnes par la communauté
même si Mélenchon reste un des rares à
penser à elle dans son programme chez
Jean-Luc Mélenchon j'aime beaucoup sa
capacité à accepter de changer d'avis de
l'humilité qui là de dire à j'ai eu tort
à cette époque là j'avais dit quelque
chose mais j'ai eu tort parce que j'ai
eu de nouvelles informations depuis et
avec ses nouvelles informations j'ai
changé d'avis et maintenant mon avis
c'est ça exemple c'était sur les
personnes transgenres il me semble je
pars de rien du tout à me dire c'est
quoi cette histoire
mon sujet quoi et puis participe à la
moyenne un peu narquois du rangement
c'est vraiment c'est un sujet bon quoi
tu sais pas si tu es un homme ou une
femme c'est quoi cette histoire bon le
truc niveau zéro quoi vous êtes
interpellé par des jeunes camarades vous
avez de l'estime pour eux de l'affection
le cousama preuve comme ça bon
réfléchir puis vous il y a ce que les
expériences je rencontre une personne
transgenre
et puis tout d'un coup le regard change
et sur plein de choses faire de la place
à toutes les identités faire la Gay
Pride avec sa mère c'est aussi ça la
génération Mélenchon
qui réinvente le présent et imagine un
futur vivable
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
peut-être parce que cette génération
tout comme Mélenchon apprend du passé et
non j'ai pas envie de revoir les gens
qui m'ont harcelé au collège et de leur
parler en mode ah ouais trop bien on est
trop potes du collège
au début des années 90 Jean-Luc et
sénateur et propose dans la foulée la
première loi pour créer un partenariat
civil le fameux PACS et j'avais un peu
en remord parce que en 1982 quand
François Mitterrand et ses gouvernements
ont aboli la punition c'était
criminalisée l'homosexualité j'ai fait
partie je pense je m'arrête j'ai pas de
souvenirs très précis de ces gens qui
faisaient non mais franchement on a on
n'a pas autre chose de plus urgent
c'était que ça la mentalité c'était non
mais attends on n'a pas dit qu'on allait
faire le socialisme alors il est où
le côté un peu rustre je pense que en
tout cas je n'ai pas compris à l'époque
de quoi on parlait et ça m'intéresse pas
et quand ces gens
arrivent
tout d'un coup je découvre ce monde
cruauté de de brutalité comme ça qu'on
avait tous sous les yeux ouais il y a eu
des pensées très sombres j'ai voulu
faire des trucs qu'il faut pas faire
il y a eu
un moment où vraiment ça allait pas du
tout et où je me faisais harceler
beaucoup beaucoup c'était en quatrième
si je dis pas de bêtises j'ai eu des
pensées suicidaires quand même à
l'époque j'ai eu des moments où j'étais
pas loin du tout et heureusement que
j'ai rien fait
et heureusement que j'ai rien fait
mais mais l'idée était là quoi
il est énorme
j'aime beaucoup une fois la même chose
tiens si vous savez pas quoi m'offrir
pour mon anniversaire je veux une grosse
[Musique]
et en colère ok j'ai les paroles
il faut chanter les champs un peu
d'extrême gauche là allez les islamos
gauchistes on chante ensemble
racisme discrimination de genre justice
écologique et sociale Jean-Luc a su
capté les intérêts d'une jeunesse
progressiste merci tout droit venu du
monde d'avant Mélenchon parviendra-t-il
à tenir le rythme de ses nouveaux
partenaires car cette jeunesse la
n’attend pas qu'on lui donne la
permission pour embrasser le nouveau
monde et ses combats d'être moi à 100%
et de le montrer autant c'est une
revanche sur toutes les personnes qui
m'ont dit que c'était pas normal d'être
moi
mon orientation sexuelle fait de moi une
minorité même si je suis un homme blanc
si genre je reste une minorité et ça m'a
permis aussi de m'ouvrir aux personnes
discriminées et du coup ça me
politiquement ça me fait aller vers des
parties qui vont aider ces personnes
l'entrée à la fac on change de vie on se
fait de nouveaux amis c'est comme se
choisir une nouvelle famille une famille
réunie autour de valeurs et de cause
commune c'est au meeting de Mélenchon
dans lequel il présente ce que sera
l'Union Populaire que j'ai rencontré les
gens qui sont aujourd'hui mes amis les
plus proches amis et du coup c'est à
partir de ce meeting là que je me suis
vraiment engagée et que j'ai pas arrêté
par la suite
je m'appelle Juliette Malbois j'ai 20
ans je suis étudiante en Information
Communication à Rennes 2 et je milite
aussi à côté de mes études
alors
première chose merci beaucoup d'être
venu nous aider après avoir fait la
campagne présidentielle et la campagne
législative je m'étais dit que je ne
pouvais pas ne plus rien faire et du
coup j'ai décidé de m'engager pleinement
dans un syndicat étudiant pour lutter
contre la précarité étudiante Juliette
découvre Jean-Luc Mélenchon en 2017 elle
a 16 ans et voit son frère militaire
pour la présidentielle trois ans plus
tard elle commence des études
supérieures à Rennes et s'engagent
auprès des jeunes insoumis loin de son
milieu d'origine je suis né à Angers
j'ai grandi dans une petite commune du
Maine-et-Loire dans le 49 à
saint-martin-d'arcé et mes parents sont
cadres et du coup je fais la petite
bourgeoisie des campagnes
on en revient à la distribution donc
vous avez vu qu'on a réparti les
produits par table selon les types de
produits les féculents l'épicerie salée
l'épicerie sucrée les fruits et les
légumes
le rôle des gens une fois qu'on a tout
installé cette semaine derrière l'étable
et je suis désolé c'est pas un travail
très amusant mais cette vérifier que les
gens ne partent pas avec plus que ce
qu'on est capable de leur donner donc
sur les épiceries salées et sucrées
c'est deux produits donc évidemment va
falloir répéter beaucoup dès que les
personnes arrivent vous leur redites et
surtout il y a du bruit ambiant il faut
le faire avec les doigts vous dites deux
points la moitié de la jeunesse
étudiante la moitié sur 2 millions ça
fait un million travail pour suivre ses
études quand moi j'étais étudiant je
sais pas on devait rien quoi 10% qui
travaillaient un peu le soir un peu si
un peu là maintenant c'est la moitié
donc c'est une une jeunesse qui a les
deux caractéristiques impliqués dans la
vie comme on dit concrète matériel et
dans l'état de de disponibilité
intellectuelle pour regarder le monde
donc ouais on peut apprendre beaucoup la
précarité étudiante on a commencé
vraiment à en parler
dans le covid mais depuis ça c'est pas
arrêté cette année ça varie entre 500 et
600 étudiants à chaque distribution
l'Union pirate c'est un syndicat
étudiant à Rennes qui est majoritaire
donc nous avec une opérat on essaie de
faire en sorte que ça se déroule au
mieux pour pas que ce soit non plus trop
une
un moment chiant parce que bon c'est pas
toujours agréable de déjà d'aller assez
distribution ça prend du temps ça prend
des fois du temps sur certains cours
c'est pas toujours agréable je pense de
montrer aux autres que voilà on est dans
une situation précarité qui nous oblige
à devoir faire 30 minutes de queue pour
pour récupérer un sac c'est le droit
deux articles sur l'ensemble de la table
je sais pas si tu as déjà pris deux
articles
tu veux reposer ça
c'est le dégoût en fait enfin j'ai
vraiment beaucoup de colère envers le
gouvernement qui qui se rend pas compte
de cette détresse là de la jeunesse et
des étudiants
[Musique]
comme Juliette de plus en plus de jeunes
privilégiés se reconnaissent dans le
mouvement de la France insoumise un
non-sens
pas tant que ça quand on connaît la
situation de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
issu d'un milieu modeste le populiste
déclare un patrimoine d'un peu plus d'un
million d'euros vous êtes bourgeois au
vous ne l'êtes pas vous voyez bien que
ça peut pas durer comme ça que on est en
train de saccager la planète je veux
dire c'est pas parce que vous êtes en
bourgeois vous avez pas de conscience
mais la conscience sociale c'est
toujours la chose qui retarde le plus
chez le chez le bourgeois il faut donc
amener je dis le bourgeois pour
caricaturer mais tout le monde peut être
convaincu moi je ne rêve que de ça
notamment dans la pratique dans mon idée
de la révolution citoyenne
répartition des richesses c'est pas pour
que c'est pas pour mes parents parce que
mes parents sont sortis globalement très
bien c'est vraiment une question je sais
pas d'égalité j'ai envie que tout le
monde soit
enfin puisse vivre dans les mêmes
conditions et que personne n'est à
s'inquiéter de comment il va finir le
mois ou comment il va nourrir ses
enfants ce soir quoi en fait tu
rencontres ceux pour qui et ce pourquoi
aussi tu te bats
[Musique]
tu connaissais l'Union pirate avant de
non oui ça fait un an que je suis à la
fac je me suis à l'origine cette année
ok trop bien et du coup ça va
alimentaire tu trouves ça en termes de
quantité ça te suffit ou pas avant
qu'est-ce que tu en penses
j'ai pas les moyens parce que je vis que
avec la bourse l'année dernière du coup
je n'avais pas du tout envie de parler
de tout ça et du coup ce que je laisse
c'est juste bah je l'ai vécu en mangeant
des pâtes
l'avenir de la France l'avenir des
insoumis c'est en partie ici qu'il se
joue
plus variés et peut-être plus équilibré
aussi même si ça c'est pas forcément
très mais par exemple il y avait des
fruits des légumes ouais ça c'est bien
mais c'est cool ok entre les boîtes de
conserve et les stickers de l'Union
pirate on aide ceux qui en ont besoin on
resote on fait de la politique
avoir un taf en parler de ces études
c'est la première cause de l'échec de
ces études c'est un sac vicieux tu vois
tant de difficulté économiquement du
coup pour payer tes études tu travailles
et au final tu mets en tu mets en danger
aussi tes études et c'est ce qui est la
macronie appelle la méritocratie tu sais
ce qui n'existe pas vraiment mdr mais du
coup voilà c'est un peu mais directement
verser un discours de gauche aussi dans
les esprits en fait voilà c'est la
solidarité c'est on organise ça parce
que le gouvernement fait rien à côté et
voilà et je pense que c'est c'est aussi
transmettre des discours de gauche qui
sont indispensables
qui sont indispensables
[Musique]
le moment où on s'installe ça y est on
est dans le vrai dans le concret la tête
dans le chantier
[Musique]
pour mettre ensuite la cuve soupe qui
nous permettra de stocker l'eau de la
source
en 2017 il y a des élections
présidentielles moi j'étais beaucoup sur
les réseaux beaucoup à commenter machin
beaucoup derrière mon ordi à lire à
répondre au gars qui faisait des
commentaires je t'ai pas un troll j'aime
pas le mot troll toi moi j'arrivais je
te faisais des pavés comme ça avec tout
l'argumentaire et parfois ça marchait je
m'appelle Simon Brakmar j'ai 31 ans et
je suis régisseur sur des tournages de
fiction je suis né au rural j'aime bien
dire ça parce que je suis encore un vrai
site italien dans l'âme mais je vais
vite maintenant à la campagne
il y a 12 ans je m'imaginais pas du tout
habiter dans un hameau avec Simon
et faire des projets potagers et
compagnie quoi Marianne et Simon sont
tous les deux intermittents du spectacle
après des années à Paris et Bruxelles
c'est 2 militants de la France insoumise
ont décidé de partir vivre au fin fond
de l'Alsace à Sainte-Marie-aux-Mines
dans le Haut-Rhin un gros projet ah
c'est du travail
de s'occuper d'une maison de devenir
autonome etc la maison en général c'est
beaucoup de travaux manuels moi je peux
du tout bricoleur donc ça va arriver
j'espère de toute façon ça viendra par
la force des choses déjà je pensais pas
être je pensais pas prendre du plaisir
autant à couper du bois etc donc ça
c'est déjà coché on sort pas trop mal on
est motivé
[Musique]
par la nécessité si dans les années qui
arrivent
on arrive à être indépendant légumes
en dépendants fruits c'est c'est tout
bénef et c'est on aura réussi ce qu'on
veut faire le couple qui installe une
cuve je comprends la démarche la crise
de l'eau j'ai dû être le seul homme
politique qui a essayé de sonner
l'alerte au niveau de la présidentielle
il y avait déjà des gens sur le plan
associatif qui faisait beaucoup de
choses mais pareil c'est une prise de
conscience il y a 5 ans 6 ans et on
comprend que c'est vital et que c'est en
train de tourner à la catastrophe et
donc je me dis je commence ma campagne
présidentielle avec ça résultat walou
zéro c'est-à-dire que ça n'a pas pris
personne n'a rebondi personne n'a voulu
entrer dans la discussion
[Musique]
donc en 2012 mon premier vote pour une
présidentielle ça a été pour ça a été
pour Mélenchon
il y a une sorte de vision il a compris
que c'était ça qu'il fallait porter
comme idée qu'il fallait allier
l'écologie le social l'Anticapitaliste
il y a une sorte de moi ça que j'aime
beaucoup dans le programme
il y a une volonté de réduire ma
dépendance un système pour être plus en
accord avec mes idées politiques aussi
les idées que je défends en tant que
militante c'est important aussi d'être
le plus en adéquation possible dans ta
vie de tous les jours il y a aussi cette
idée là que j'ai un enfant on s'est posé
la question de faire de faire un enfant
c'était déjà de dans quel monde notre
fille grandira quoi
avoir la responsabilité d'un autre être
humain ça remet en question c'est
priorités ça peut aussi accentuer
certaines angoisses c'est rouge ce sera
joli
là il fait 3000 donc oui ça change là
notre petite info là
il y a aussi le fait que pour moi il y a
plus de sécurité à habiter à la campagne
il y a un côté de moi qui me dit que
l'effondrement peut peut-être arriver un
jour et à ce moment-là il faudra être
protégé mais je leur dis je comprends ce
que vous faites mais attention les amis
la solution c'est pas chacun pour soi
chacun sa cuve de flotte chacun son
générateur d'électricité chacun non la
solution les collectives c'est une autre
gestion de l'eau dans le pays économe
prudente méthodique et là c'est pas en
régulant l'eau au moment de se brosser
les dents qu'on va régler le problème de
l'eau dans le pays c'est en expropriant
les compagnies privées qui exploitent
l'eau c'est en organisant des
coopératives bref c'est en ayant une
action sociale agir pour la cause agir
pour soi le dilemme de toute personne
engagée et si les deux étaient
compatibles moi déjà je suis un fils de
militant je suis un enfant d'Estos
racisme mes parents se sont rencont ce
sera six mais à l'époque j'ai grandi
avec mon père qui me racontait sa vie de
militant qui m'a appris ce que c'était
que head de gauche ce que c'était
les inégalités est-ce que c'était de
lutter contre les inégalités donc j'ai
grandi dans la politique le truc c'est
que là moi j'arrivais un stade où il va
falloir que je recommence à militer non
pas très longtemps parce que mine de
rien quand tu es loin de ce qui des
choses qui se passent tu es tout de
suite largué et
moi ça me manque un ça commence à me
manquer un petit peu aussi
[Musique]
un matin on se lève
tout est devenu mécanique ça y est la
routine nous a piégé bonjour monsieur
dimanche dernier donc on peut gagner
cette fois sauf que sur notre route une
rencontre va nous réveiller du genre
femme brillante et expérimentée c'est
passion le changement et l'environnement
voilà donc là on a on est devant au
premier tour mais de pas grand chose
assez clair le jeune j'ai 28 ans et je
suis en test de sciences politiques et à
côté je suis militante depuis un certain
nombre d'années maintenant bonjour
et on va bloquer les prix surtout
c'est une des mesures clés dans le
programme si on gagne merci au moment de
la montée en puissance du mouvement
climat et notamment du mouvement climat
jeune en France j'étais secrétaire
finale des jeunes écologistes
des jeunes femmes comme claire Lejeune
sont les personnes qui dans la
génération de la qui arrive vont être
les organisatrices de la planification
dans notre pays c'est vraiment une belle
prise je trouve qui elle
vous prend une chose elle existe en
plusieurs exemplaires pas identiques
mais des jeunes gens qui ont cette
puissance de caractère de volonté
d'engagement et clarté intellectuelle
donc de ce point de vue je dors
tranquille la relève est vraiment
assurée des jeunes gens engagés avec
Claire Jean-Luc a trouvé une camarade
solide pour faire sa révolution
citoyenne j'ai voulu faire la campagne
de Mélenchon aussi parce que c'était à
mon sens la seule campagne qui se
donnait vraiment comme but de gagner
rien d'autre quand on regarde le bilan
on a recréé une forme d'unité à gauche
sur la base d'un score qui était quand
même de 22% ce qui est immense c'est à
dire que là on s'est remis du
hollandisme on a mis à distance
cette gauche qui dit qui en fait avec
complètement intégré que bon il y a le
système tel qu'il est puis on va essayer
de le rendre un petit peu mon brutal
quoi voilà et en fait c'est pas l'enjeu
très peu classe l'enjeu pour ma
génération c'est de changer le système
sauf que sortir du capitalisme c'est
comme sortir de son canapé quand on y
est confortablement installé depuis des
années et des années on voit pas tout de
suite l'intérêt et ça même quand on est
de gauche le cœur de la doctrine à
l'époque comme professeait le socialisme
c'était le développement des forces
productives donc c'était vraiment une
vision extrêmement productiviste en gros
moi je me rappelle avoir dit Oh avec le
capitalisme c'est une deux chevaux pour
les pauvres une Mercedes pour les riches
avec nous Mercedes pour tout le monde
quel bêtise bon bah oui c'est
productivisme ça c'est allez en avant le
lavoir fait l'être bon de tout ça si
vous voulez j'ai compris que l'écologie
politique
offrait un angle un balcon complètement
différent pour regarder le monde qui me
permettait de refaire une synthèse entre
mes objectifs sociaux parce que pour moi
l'écologie c'est une question sociale
c'est que sociale remettre en question
tous nos modèles de vie pour se lancer
dans la grande aventure de la
planification écologique c'est beau sur
le papier mais c'est parfois un peu
risqué surtout quand on a besoin
d'embarquer un maximum de gens pour que
ça marche
le moment où vraiment cette politisation
s'est transformée en engagement ça
faisait 3-4 ans que je faisais que
travailler et j'avais vraiment une perte
de sens on passe nos vies dans les
bouquins c'est extrêmement instructif
pour nous sur le plan personnel mais moi
je fais enfin je suis là aussi parce que
je veux je veux que les choses changent
etc on raconte un autre monde possible
et le but c'est de faire de faire que ça
devienne possible dans la tête des gens
et à partir du moment où ça devient
possible dans la tête des gens bah ça se
traduit dans les urnes et puis ça se
traduit on l'espère voilà dans une prise
de pouvoir marier la théorie et la
pratique après des années à militer sur
le terrain auprès des migrants des 100
logements claire la doctorante est là
comme ça
ça montre qu'on est vraiment venu en
vrai de vrai
pas le choix clair et sa génération
doivent composer avec l'héritage des 30
glorieuses
ça peut passer on est en tête au premier
tour
ça peut passer
dans la vie on pourrait pas grand chose
donc on boit pas
au calme
on va et tout là on va être sur le banc
c'est ça qu'on a essayé de changer
monsieur
on n'a pas le pouvoir là-dessus le
pouvoir politique le pouvoir politique
on le connaît le pouvoir politique faut
arrêter on est délaissé mais je le
comprends vous ne le comprenez pas parce
que vous me vivez pas vous ne pouvez pas
le comprendre claire et sa génération
doivent accepter la dure réalité les
nouveaux partenaires payent souvent les
pots cassés de nos histoires passées
j'ai 27 ans je sens pas responsable de
toutes les politiques de droite qui ont
été menées dans le pays sur la question
du mal logement et la question de la
précarité et justement nous on essaye de
faire changer tout ça après moi je
comprends sa colère et j'ai pas j'ai pas
d'arguments à lui opposer juste
peut-être l'écouter essayer de montrer
que
on comprend enfin et que on essaie de
faire de notre mieux merci merci
beaucoup bonsoir
ça va
un insoumi en général on peut le
distinguer de tous les autres parce que
c'est lui qui vous pouvez le repas du
dimanche donc il va amener le sujet
politique et provoquer le bazar
la période délicate des désaccords
impossible d'y échapper comment gérer ça
au mieux on peut s'asseoir autour d'une
table et discuter
alors à table on fait toujours comme ça
on éteint les téléphones on perd Pascal
et cadre dans l'entreprise du coin et il
y a ma mère Yolaine qui est
fonctionnaire qui travaille dans un
lycée voilà
bon appétit les jeunes
et les moins jeunes
première greffe de sa vie mais attends
c'est important mon père lui
politiquement et si tu as droites mais
bon on discute quand même plutôt bien
avec lui de plus en plus ma mère elle
avait pour habitude de voter comme mon
père et depuis 2022 elle s'est mise à
beauté à gauche et voilà un peu plus
selon ses propres idéal quoi nous on va
à Paris chez les jeunes tu vas toi
exprimer son point de vue se confronter
aux autres et si le conflit permettait
aussi d'avancer j'ai toujours trouvé que
Mélenchon c'était un très bon orateur
oui mais c'est un des meilleurs c'est
vrai que quand on est quand on l'écoute
quand on change
politique raconte des bêtises je sais
pas c'est l'effet Juliette c'est
peut-être l'effet des enfants de manière
générale bon là et on est quand même
trois enfants
j'ai pas changé je trouve non j'ai pas
changé je trouve que je trouve qu'il y a
de plus les écarts sont de plus en plus
importants et c'est pas normal
les écarts n'étaient pas aussi
importants de ça il y a 10 ans non non
ça implique quoi d'écouter la jeunesse
aujourd'hui
d'accepter de se remettre en cause non
je suis pas sûr je suis pas sûr d'être
de gauche enfin rien je sais pas mais
mais
en politique de bord je connais pas
grand chose et de une alors c'est pas
alors je suis désolé mais c'est pas
parce que Juliette et les fils pas du
tout je suis pas dit un jour ah les
jeunes formidables ils vont m'apprendre
des trucs c'est quelque chose que j'ai
appris sur moi-même comment moi je
m'étais enfermé alors peut-être que si
parce que à force de
indirectement peut-être mais
la vie démantée absolument tout ce à
quoi on avait cru on sait donc tellement
trompé tu as juste peut-être peut-être
mais si vous acceptez pas de vous faire
secouer
bon je sais pas vous aimez qu'on
vous
mais oui j'aime bien aller au contact de
ce que je comprends pas
ou qui trouve l'incertitude oui oui oui
mais Mollo c'est pas de l'extérieur
c'est moi qui décide moi je comprends
pas si tu es arrivé donc bon
d'oreille
et toi aussi tu penses que de ton côté
tu as mûri aussi tu tu réfléchis
peut-être un peu plus avant de parler je
pense que et moi aussi peut-être
probablement
faire preuve de maturité qui doit
montrer l'exemple les parents ou les
enfants les représentants ou les
citoyens dans les familles politiques
comme dans les vrais familles les rôles
sont parfois inversés
ça me saoule je trouve un peu con
parfois après il y a pas de pluie
tout ce qui touche à la politique moi ça
m'emmerde j'ai eu l'espoir c'est parti
vite l'affaire katnens et le soutien de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon au député condamné
pour violence conjugales comment ne pas
être déçu quand on croit à de meilleurs
rapports homme-femme comment ne pas
douter de ses propres choix politiques
quand on est féministe et convote pour
la France insoumise
je sais pas si on a le droit de
je sais pas
oui
au moment de la faire quand j'ai lu ça
l'être bah je me souviens avoir été
très triste pour être honnête
et puis par derrière j'ai pensé aussi à
la victime du coup ça sa femme et
donc voilà donc c'est une histoire qui a
fait vachement parler et tant mieux si
c'est pour parler des violences que
subissent les femmes Jean-Louis
Mélenchon a fait des tweets du coup qui
qui était pas forcément nécessaire je
pense qui était un peu maladroit et qui
aurait pu être bien meilleur
[Musique]
si vous communiquez et que vous
n'arrivez pas au but que vous vous fixez
vous pouvez vous dire faut faire mieux
quoi bon donc clairement ma manière de
m'exprimer dans cette circonstance
pouvait pas s'entendre comme je voulais
j'ai commencé par vous dire que elle a
raison de dire que c'est maladroit pas
parce que c'est faux
parce que ça ne correspond pas à ce que
je veux dire et à l'époque pourquoi
madame attendez parce que
je comprends qu'on dise ah oui mais il y
a une exemplarité bon ok donc on en
parle mais on en parle comme des sujets
si vous voulez on essaye d'avoir tous
une attitude rationnelle et une attitude
qui va essayer de de penser au futur
d'être conforme à nos principes je suis
pas obligé de réviser ma position à
cause de vous bah pourquoi pas non non
j'aurais mieux fait de me taire c'est ce
qu'il y a de mieux bon on essaie de
la conclusion
juste avec le fait que vous vouliez dire
quand vous nous avez dit faites
mieux si vous pouvez
comment poursuivre la relation quand la
confiance est abîmée
on peut se consoler avec des choses
simples
comme un bon vieux principe on n'est
jamais mieux servi que par soi-même tu
m'as dit
[Musique]
faites mieux comment interpréter les
mots de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
faites mieux est-ce une invitation ça
disait j'ai fini ma tâche et maintenant
faites mieux c'est la vôtre déjà ça
m'incite encore plus à donner de
moi-même et à faire mieux justement
faites mieux ça sonne un peu comme un
défi non
faites gagner nos idées faites en sorte
que on arrive au pouvoir et qu'on change
vraiment les choses croyez-vous
ça c'est un peu plus compliqué faites
mieux c'est peut-être un conseil toi
aussi fais mieux Mélenchon en fait tu
contrôle pas ce que tu dis tu es tout le
temps en colère tu contrôle mal ta
colère c'est un peu culotté je trouve
venant d'une certaine génération de dire
aux jeunes faites mieux sachant que tout
le comportement des jeunes au final
c'est des résultats des de la génération
précédente
donc on fait mieux on essaie de faire
avec ce qu'on a en fait
comment ne pas tomber dans le piège de
nos schémas je m'adresse pas un jeune
comme un jeune au sens de ah tu es un
petit jeune attention je te caresse la
tête je vais t'expliquer la vie je fais
pas ça comment échapper à nos
contradictions je suis un peu
terrealiste absolument incorrigible
comment se libérer de celui qui nous a
ouvert le chemin quand la loyauté et le
respect s'en mêle aujourd'hui sans
Jean-Luc Mélenchon la France insoumise
sera pas avec 75 députés à l'Assemblée
nationale au final il y a ni grand amour
ni homme politique providentiel il y a
des histoires simples dans un monde
idéal on mange à sa fin et de grandes
aventures mon rêve c'est on arrive à
refaire collectif en fait déjà
et peut-être qu'en essayant de sortir de
nos rôles
faire mieux en quelque sorte y compris
en tant qu'individu et ben il faut qu'on
arrive à s'améliorer à être conscient de
ces mécanismes patriarcos peut-être
qu'en sono la fin d'une culture celle du
Père
peut-être qu'on arrête en attendre qu'on
nous passe le flambeau ont réussira un
jour à faire mieux je dirais que mon
chef politique idéal ce serait une femme
écolo des cœurs plein de coeurs je peux
faire des cartes
[Musique]